what up space fam golsan here from anime
uproar
back at it again to discuss the latest
episode of the attack on titan final
season
and this is the turning point ladies and
gentlemen clashing philosophies
and clashing titan battles make sure to
stay tuned for that if you do
enjoy seeing these attack on titan
videos and want to keep them coming then
the best thing to do
is warhammer smash that like button and
share this video with any attack on time
fans that you know
if you haven't be sure to subscribe and
this is crucial hit that notification
bell and select all or you will miss
future attack on time videos
and while you wait for the next insane
episode to drop feel free to check out
my growing attack on time playlist where
we got videos about the titan shifters
and their powers
all the acronyms and their powers the
titans rank for weak as the strongest
and much more link to that is in the
description now without further ado
let's jump into it
spoilers and all so this episode episode
65 is called the warhammer titan which
is hella exciting because the warhammer
titan is the new and final ninth titan
that we've been waiting for
for so long things just don't get more
hyped than a new titan after aaron
declared war on the world
if you're like me and don't care about
spoilers and want to know as much as
possible about the warhammer titan how
strong it is and what happens to it then
i recommend you check out my how strong
is the warhammer titan video
which i'll link in the description but
for now in the anime it remains new
interesting and mysterious however we
don't just continue where we left off
with the last episode which was with
aaron's titan about to eat willie tiber
that specific moment actually happened
at the end of chapter 100 of the manga
which you gotta admit it's a crazy thing
to happen
and it's fitting for such an important
chapter milestone
especially because we get to meet the
warhammer titan in chapter 101.
isayama did a great job with making the
100th chapter special and of course that
hype transferred over to the anime too
last episode was the lead up and initial
transformation
but this episode is where things really
go full gear and all hell breaks loose
before that though we get some willy
tyber flashback moments
the manga didn't interrupt this part
with a flashback but i think they wanted
to end the last episode in a hype way
and so they decided to push some stuff
like the conversation between mageth and
willy to the next episode in the form of
a flashback and it's not a bad move
necessarily because as a dude is getting
eaten you probably want to get a sense
of what kind of guy he
is so this episode starts with the
flashback so willy's death has some
impact on us even though he's a
relatively new member of the cast
compared to aaron mikasa and the rest
we see him getting humanized which is
something isayama loves to do let me
know if there's even one character you
can think of who is
pure evil in this show because i don't
think there is for the most part isayama
does such a good job of showing how if
you switch the perspective
almost anyone can be seen as the good
guy or at least as a complex human being
no one just hates everyone else and
wants to destroy everyone for fun they
all have
characters that they are acting to
protect even though their actions may be
horrible
willie is clearly the enemy of aaron
although he sees himself as the savior
here wanting to show the world that
aaron is dangerous and that the
internment zone aldians aren't in league
with the devil aaron jaeger he's also
ready to sacrifice many lives in order
to get that point across
he's prepared to be attacked by aaron
and willing to give his own life in the
process which even if you don't like him
you have to respect that he's willing to
die for a cause he believes in
when he doesn't have to he can just
chill out in his rich home with his
special tiber status
and await the end in style if it comes
but rather he's throwing himself in
harm's way even though he has a family
they spend time showing willy with the
tiber kids who love him
even though aaron has been the
protagonist since the beginning of the
series isayama is showing in this
episode that that doesn't necessarily
mean he's 100
the good guy and on the right side not
that a quote unquote 100 percent good
side
even seems to exist in this world aaron
kills this man without mercy the man we
got to know relatively well in part with
help from this flashback he seems to
want to help the world and aldians at
large from his perspective but to do so
he's willing to sacrifice aldian lives
because he knows aaron will kill
others and that's baked into his plan
the conversation between willy and
maggeth is really good
maggith at first questions the idea of
having aldians die
because of aaron's attack but then tiber
points out that it's not that different
now
just because they're not in uniform
maggeth has sent plenty of aldians out
to die on the battlefield
and the most haunting and powerful line
in my opinion is when maggath says that
he has no doubt that the eldians are
spawns of the devil
as he reaches out his hand to shake
willie's willy has clearly earned his
respect
and then maggeth adds and we are devils
too meaning the marlenes maggath
recognizes that aldians are no more
devils than marlenes or other humans
this is a recurring theme in attack on
titan the ability to turn into titans
is not what makes you a devil evil seems
to be present in all of humanity or at
least the potential of evil furthermore
evil
fuels evil so when someone attacks a
group of people they in turn seek
revenge and the cycle continues and
gains steam
as the deaths and tragedies pile up in
reality every character we've seen
has some good in them and some evil in
them and anyone can become a devil
because the world of attack on titan is
creating devils all the time aaron
didn't just attack
willy-nilly he counter-attacked after
the marlenes attacked his home
and killed many of his people including
his mom so
this time when he attacked them the way
he was attacked it's still messed up and
he's killing innocent people even
children but he's acting in the way he
was taught to act by his enemies
he's fighting back fighting fire with
fire he's definitely not an innocent
character anymore but he's doing what he
thinks he has to do
not even just for revenge but to protect
the people he loves and cares about
because remember with technology
aldian's and titan powers
are in the process of becoming obsolete
and when that happens
nobody will want to keep the monsters
that turn into titans
and attack their people and kill their
families alive everyone fears them
and when they're not needed aaron
believes they'll be eradicated and that
goes double for the island aldians on
paradise island who
are already no use to the world alive
the image of aaron eating willy is truly
horrifying you can totally see why the
world views aldeans as devils during
this scene
another crazy detail is how it happens
during a play
a lot of these people are high society
people who would never be on the front
lines
and now they're confronted with what
appears to be the devil himself in front
of them
and it must be absolutely terrifying
it's like if you were watching tv
felt safe enough with your comfortable
life and a titan suddenly popped out of
the ground
many of these people died because of
aaron's appearance
here aaron is bringing the war to them
in a very laloosh
if you kill be prepared to be killed
kind of way zofia and eventually udo die
two kids you could say they're not
completely innocent because they're
warrior candidates but in reality
they're just doing what they've been
brainwashed to think is the right thing
at that age you arguably can't even be
blamed for your actions they're around
gabby's age and gabby is only 12 years
old
then the warhammer titan appears it is
willie tiber's sister who remained
nameless in the manga but here we learn
she is called lara
tiber a very cool piece of info for
manga fans
she clearly has a sort of maid disguise
thing going on
so you might have even questioned
whether or not she was a legit part of
the family so for all of you sherlock's
that knew
it was her immediately good job because
they definitely kept her
in the background during the tiber
scenes i love aaron's quick reflexes
here
he goes for the punch before the tiber
sister has even finished transforming
and completely destroys her nape let me
know if you anime only watchers took
note of the fact that she formed her
titan from the feet
up instead of the nape aaron only later
figures it out and that that's the
reason she doesn't die when her nape is
destroyed or when mikasa later shoots
thunderspears at her nape while this is
all going on
maggot fires a symbolic counter-attack
at aaron's titan
signaling the fact that the nation is at
war with aaron now again this is funny
because
aaron's attack is a counter-attack in
and of itself so they shouldn't be
acting like completely innocent victims
here
what marlei is doing right now is more
so a counter counter attack i love
finally seeing the warhammer and his
powers animated
obviously the 3d stuff can be a bit
jarring not gonna lie about that
let me know how you feel about it but
nonetheless i am so glad to finally see
it animated and honestly the cgi gives
the titans a creepy look
that kind of works because they're
supposed to be creepy
but anyways we see the warhammer impale
aaron with a giant spike
and then form a warhammer with spikes on
the end of it aaron's titan gets its
head knocked off after
it's trapped by warhammer spikes that
jut out of the ground
it leads to a very cool scene where
aaron is protruding from his titan body
he's about to get killed here but
luckily mikasa shows up
so good to see the survey core again
mikasa thunder spears the tiber's sister
but as we know
it doesn't have any effect because she's
not in the nape
i gotta say the warhammer titan power
really delivered something special
it uses its hardening to create anything
you can think of
including whips swords warhammer spikes
and as we later see a freaking crossbow
this extremely creative titan power was
definitely worth the wait
i always compare it to an earthbender
from avatar even the warhammer itself
is just an empty body obeying the
commands of its user
while she stays underground in one of
those unbreakable titan crystals
and despite this the titan can talk
perfectly
joining the other few titan talkers like
zeke and peek
there are so many animation highlights
throughout like when you see mikasa
upside down after launching the thunder
spears into the warhammer titan i love
seeing how the vertical maneuvering gear
lets them fly around the city like
spider-man
mikasa ends up telling aaron to come
home and you can tell that things are
complicated between them at this point
and that aaron has been
acting without their approval i really
ship these too
hard even though i doubt that attack on
titan is the kind of show that will give
its characters especially air and a
happy ending
it's hard to give a guy who just killed
a bunch of innocent people
and even kids a happy ending we're told
that aaron succeeded
in making sure every major nation gets
involved in the war
and that they'll see the eldean empire
as a threat the way willy wanted
of course aaron probably felt in line
with machiavelli's philosophy that if he
gives them something to fear
they'll be less likely to mess with him
it's really hard to know
what the right approach is in this kind
of situation where the lives of your
entire people are on the line
floch supports aaron not wanting to show
any mercy to the people that caused
their people to be eaten alive
he feels that they have it coming while
gene has a more objective approach
understanding that they're humans too
not just the enemy or devils
and what's crazy is that in a way aaron
has become a villain now
mikasa asks if he even knows what he's
done since he killed civilians and
children
crazy to think our shonen protagonist
did something like this
best girl mikasa cries while telling
aaron that this can't be
undone and aaron is completely
emotionless
he clearly knows what he did was messed
up but he has a mission
and he won't let his emotions stop him
now from moving forward and carrying it
out
this is when the crossbow gets fired and
aaron is only saved because mikasa saves
him here
but again how crazy is it that through
hardening the warhammer can create a
crossbow
it's like momo from my hero academia the
possibilities are seemingly endless as
long as the warhammer titan has the
knowledge to envision what it wants to
create aaron is pretty calm cool and
collected despite
everything saying he plans to eat the
warhammer titan and gain a third titan
power we also see gabby's face which
seems to be filled with pure hatred this
is exactly like when aaron was attacked
on paradise island
and was filled with hate for the titans
just in this case gabby is directing her
hate at aaron in the survey core
specifically
sasha our precious potato girl who is
looking very good mind you after the
time skip
shoots an officer the one who was nice
to gabby but importantly she
spares gabby who she's viewing as an
innocent harmless
child clearly sasha isn't taking the
same merciless approach
as aaron aaron finally notices the cable
attached to the warhammer leading it to
underneath the stage he transforms and
takes out the user and her titan crystal
while severing the cord which causes the
warhammer titan body to collapse
although this is an op titan this is a
problematic situation because we can
assume a lot of energy was spent
creating this titan body and by cutting
a cable it all seems to be wasted
then as if things can't get more hype
porco
another titan comes in having been
rescued thanks to peak who knew
something was shady about the person
leading them to the trap and so hug the
men that ride her titan and let them
know to secretly follow her
despite how weird that sentence sounded
i really like that pique is so
quick-witted
i love when characters plan things out
so intelligently without anyone catching
on
so points go to peak for that when porco
is about to take out aaron
levi comes in and slices his jaw so fast
that he can't close it arguably the
third time
aaron's life was saved by an ackerman in
this episode alone by the way i love
seeing the draw titan animated
and its hardened claws are cool to see
up close
as a manga fan it's really cool to see
all these titans and characters colored
and from different
angles i also had no idea flocci's hair
was going to be orange
it's so interesting to see how porco
reacts to the survey core he's in
disbelief that humans are attacking a
titan the hunter has become the hunted
and he's shocked that they are in fact
hunting him
and trying to kill him rather than the
other way around and in the case of
mikasa and levi they arguably
outdo most titans so we got a whole
different ball game right now something
completely different to what these
marlene warriors are used to
and that is it for this epic episode
leaving plenty insane moments for the
next one
we get a preview for the next episode
and see that the car
titan and beast titan are joining in
it's called assault so we know that the
action will only ramp up and we're just
gonna keep having more and more insane
people enter the fight and i gotta say
absolutely love this attack on titan
season
i am so excited each week to watch the
episodes and i think all in all they're
doing a great job
as a manga reader i kind of have my own
perceptions on what's going on
since i know what's gonna happen next
with these characters but i'd love to
know if you're an anime only watcher
how you're experiencing this for the
first time are you still on air inside
no matter what did you empathize at all
with willy and the others aaron attacked
i'm very curious to know if this marley
portion of the season
has shifted some people's perspective a
bit and changed the way they look at the
good guys and the bad guys in this
series
and that is it for this episode if you
do enjoy seeing these attack on titan
videos and want to keep them coming then
the best thing you could do is warhammer
smash that like button and share this
video with any attack on titan fans that
you know
if you haven't be sure to subscribe and
this is crucial hit that notification
bell and select all or you will miss
future attack on titan videos and while
you wait for the next
insane episode to drop feel free to
check out our growing attack on titan
playlist where we got videos about all
of the titan shifters and their powers
the acronyms and their powers the titans
ranked from weakest to strongest
and much more link to that is in the
description and until next time
see ya space cowboys
[Music]
you